ich habe angst als oder was ist
eigentlich frage ich mache alles okay
das ist nur schon mal irgendwie so gar
nichts glauben ist nur leute ersten
fahrt etwas glaubt willkommen beim neuen
video erneute ich bin so aufgeregt und
ich freue mich mega das wird auf jeden
fall mit abstand eines meiner größten
video wir haben heute nämlich eine menge
vor und zwar bekomme ich heute endlich
ich habe wirklich jetzt lange darauf
gewartet aber heute ist eigentlich so
weit ich bekomme mein neues auto
beziehungsweise mein erstes eigenes auto
und ich bin gerade noch zu hause wir
müssen jetzt gleich nach duisburg ich
war da wird schon ziemlich oft ich
glaube jetzt zum vierten mal heute ja
und heute ist mein auto endlich da und
ich kann es mitnehmen es ist ja auch
mein erstes eigenes auto ich hatte
vorher noch nie ein auto und stehen euch
natürlich mit ich will nicht langsamer
gefahren jetzt los wird bestimmt sehr
ausführlicher blog also ich hab ja bock
drauf und letzten schreibkunst in die
kommentare
welche reise südwesten oder das also
entweder von euch hat sie sagen jetzt
mal rechts oder links und ich sage
rechtlich wort darauf dass mein kaffee
bekommen bank schnell meine leute werden
mit etwa 56 und um 13 uhr müsste ich ein
star sein wenn ich das schaffe oder wir
dann wollen wir erstmal das auto ab und
dann wollten noch noch düsseldorf ein
bisschen shoppen bis gleich
[Musik]
so leute wie sie jetzt schon in duisburg
wir sind sofort da gab's einen vortrag
geschickt bekommen davon zeigt es das
mal kurz wenn ich noch nervöser aber ich
frag mich so wie soll ich das auto aus
dem auto raus noch 500 meter dann haben
wir unser ziel erreicht
[Musik]
leute wir sind wir sofort da ist okay
leute
[Musik]
was ist aber ich trage schwer
irgendwie so ganz glauben
warum kümmert er sich traurig gefahren
weil ich würde sagen okay leute bevor
weitermachen wir machen dann erst mal in
fahrt
okay leute warten jetzt mal bis für die
autoschlüssel bekommen und dann hab ich
mich einsetzen
ich bin auch wenn ich noch gar nicht
probe gefahren oder sonst was also es
ist das erste mal dass es gleich muss
beim phase nach finde ich dass der
scheiß wert was dann freue mich mega
also man kann das gar nicht beschreiben
kann es echt nicht in worte fassen zu
wollen dass es so schnell passiert also
irgendwie egal schritt weder noch mal
darüber
[Musik]
es gehört zum ersten mal drin voll
scheiße nicht sofort für 14 guck mal
firma nach hinten
guck mal wie eng es ein bis dahin
erklärung
[Musik]
viel erklären bereich bislang auch recht
genaue verfahren auch unter 3000 raus
gefahren weil ich kann natürlich raus
war nachher wird irgendwo ne macke rein
guckt euch mal an dass sie durch diese
tür so dass wasser angekommen
albert gute fahrt okay leute kurzer
soundcheck ist bin ich auch noch
gespannt ich muss dazu auch gleich noch
was sagen es ist sondern der normale
mustern oder eco bußmann unternehmen
will aber wir machen trotzdem setzen
nur 90 erste fahrt noch warten die fans
noch nach düsseldorf er selbst wusste
ich dass mir so reinfährt
ich schwöre das ist so geil ging ich
glaubte ich habe einfach ein auto
notpaket
angeblich warten jetzt gerade vielleicht
zwei kilometer und dann sofort autobahn
also leute vielleicht ein paar kleine
worte im auto ist meine ich bin ja grad
19 und ich habe jetzt erst mal den ford
mustang akkus beruhigt natürlich dank
vielen mustern gehört einem v8 motor bei
ist ein amerikanisches kult ausgleich
mal nur das teil hatte 300 ps und der gc
hat glaube ich 420 und 3 117 ps sind von
mega viel und ich hab da auf jeden fall
respekt vor dem team genommen
der ist doch ein bisschen
umweltfreundlicher bisschen weniger
spritverbrauch und ich finde das passt
erst mal gut zu mir und wenn ich dann
unbedingt irgendwann mal den gt haben
möchte dann kann ich mir den halt auch
in drei jahren vielleicht mal zulegen
als erweiterung aber ich bin auf jeden
fall mega mega kraft zufrieden mit dem
auto auch mit der farbe mit allem
einfach das schnell und weitere sachen
einfach später nochmal wir fahren jetzt
erst mal gleich auf die autobahn und
dann geht erst mal bist du das essen und
ich freue mich das kann man gar nicht
beschreiben das gefühl ist auf jeden
fall megageil natürlich kann man an
dieser stelle auch mal sagen danke dass
ihr mich unterstützt weil ich machen
wenn ich kein youtube dann könnte ich
jetzt nicht mein auto fahren oder hätte
ich nicht so viele von euch die hat
meine bücher schauen und sonst was also
mega dank stetig weiter täglich sehr zu
schätzen ja hätte mir vor zwei jahren
jemand gesagt hey du fährst in zwei
jahren muss das war immer mein traum auf
den vogel gezeigt und jetzt ist einfach
so irgendwie voll schnell passiert
dankeschön wir sind dann zusätzlich
dürfte jetzt noch was setzen ich habe
gerade locker eine halbe stunden
verkürzen weil ich muss erst mal parken
denn mit dem auto weil die sozia
logischerweise ein bisschen länger als
andere autos aber jetzt gibt es etwas zu
essen heute geht auf meinen nacken
[Musik]
so leicht wie man jetzt einfach noch bis
20 uhr 13 düsseldorf jetzt haben nach
hause habt ihr schon geschlafen und nach
aber das habe ich geschafft nachhaltig
[Musik]
b
leute ich bin jetzt eigentlich zwar sich
für mich immer noch mit dem handy also
zumindest das taschenlampen nicht davon
damit steht auf jeden fall bin ich froh
jetzt ehrlich zu sein war ultra
anstrengt heute ich hoffe der blogger
durchgefallen last auf jeden fall nach
oben jack ma lin snapshot ab und ihr
könnt ja gern meine kommentare schreiben
ob ihr das auto cool findet oder ob die
ein anderes auto liga will keine ahnung
also was ich wirklich noch mal am ende
sagen muss ich weiß selber dass es nicht
selbstverständlich so früh sein auto
fahren zu können oder zu dürfen und für
mega stolz drauf dass ich das jetzt
irgendwie hinbekommen habe um ehrlich zu
sein finde ich schwer zu sagen dass ich
mir das sogar so mega verdient hab aber
ich weiß nich schon ziemlich oft sind
nicht viel gearbeitet habe und so dafür
und deswegen kann ich auch sagen dass
ich das match boden gerissen fahren kann
und auch auf jeden fall aufpassen werde
weil ich meine es ist auch kein auto was
man vielleicht zu früh unbedingt fahren
wollte ich meinen stolz auf mein
führerschein schon zweieinhalb jahre ich
halte mehr mit tipps angenommen als
erfahrung habe ich auf jeden fall schon
jetzt natürlich nicht die mega erfahrung
aber ich weiß wie ich damit umgehen kann
und ich habe mehr respekt davor halt
drauf zu drücken und plötzlich ist man
bei 200 oder so deswegen hat sich da
wirklich darauf also brauchen sich keine
sorgen zu machen gerade weil ich einfach
nicht mehr sagen wirklich danke für
alles und für megastars in welcher
glücklich wir sehen uns dann wahlweise
wieder rein